[Music]
welcome back to our next episode of
what's up prof welcome back
walter this is becoming a habit yes
i'm enjoying this habit i think it's a
healthy habit will you open up for us
with a word of prayer please absolutely
heavenly father there are such
incredible events taking place in the
world
and there's so much turmoil and so much
pain
and so much antagonism
it is as if the world is being
subjected to forces beyond
its control and the only one who has
everything in his hands is our god
and so i pray lord that you will be with
us as we discuss these things
may your spirit be with us in jesus name
amen amen
we're going to start with a subject
that's not
an easy subject and that's the black
lives matter
and i would also like from my side just
to make it
from the beginning clear that
if you in today's if you're a christian
and you see color and not a human being
then you've got a problem because the
bible makes it clear
in the commandments and jesus summed up
the commandments saying that
love to god and love to your
neighbor and nowhere in
neighbor there's a color
or a race a seed or anything anything or
a nation
so that's our standpoint
if i can speak for you as well that's
where we
where we come from yes there's no
right white black it is all human beings
well let's just recap a little bit this
is the last one now in the series north
versus south
we we thought we could do it in one but
it ended up as three right
well north versus south we were
discussing
the ideologies that are
in national boundaries and across
national boundaries
and amongst all of these issues we as
background before we started with the
north versus south
we used the the elements that we
discussed
in the doctrine of the serpent how the
serpent theology
has permeated virtually the whole of
humanity
and the mother of this doctrine we saw
was roman catholicism
and this is babylonian wine that has
been
poured out and the nations
have drunk the wine and so
they are drunk with the wine of babylon
and so we have to
always compare scripture
with the ideologies out there are we
talking scriptural
ideologies or are we talking serpent
ideologies and we need to bear
that in mind as well so everything is in
the context
of an ideological clash which
eventually when north and south come
together in a synthesis
will end in the ultimate ideological
clash
between those that have swallowed the
babylonian
mode of thinking versus those who are
with the biblical mode of thinking and
these are the filters that we are
applying and everything
that we see happening in the world must
be in that context
yes that's very important
so one of the serpent lies was
you shall not surely die and
this one of course plays an incredible
role
in the terms of babylonian thinking
and if you believe that when you die
you don't die that you continue as a
spirit entity
well then spiritism and spiritualism
becomes
the norm it becomes probable yes
and if you look at the television
broadcasts over the last
number of years how many how many
programs instill that thought
into your mind that you can communicate
with the dead that you can
be in communion with those that have
as some claim crossed over
whereas the bible has a totally
different teaching
in god the dead are not really dead they
are sleeping
and that means they're not waking
entities
doing something else they are sleeping
what do you do when you sleep
do you go walking around doing things no
you are asleep right
so this is what the bible says what the
condition of death
is and from that condition there will be
a resurrection
and god is not dependent on
the material that was initially you
he will call and you will come forth
with a glorified body which is like
unto his glorious body and
we talked about issues like that as well
so this was one of the great serpent
lies and how does this permeate
humanity even the christian churches
have adopted this babylonian wine
even though their founders like martin
luther and tyndall
believed the biblical version their
followers don't
and that's just a fact of history so
let's have a look
at a verse which i find is
very important when it comes to
discussing
issues of nationality race
etc it's it's very touchy ground
and we come from south africa where it
is touchy to the power of 10. yes
so acts chapter 17 verse 26
tells us where we come from talking
about god and it says
and has made of one blood
all nations of men for to dwell
on all the face of the earth and has
determined the times before appointed
and the bounds
of their habitation
you know i've given quite a number of
lectures on
genetics and in my evolution creation
series
there is also a lecture on genetics the
genes
of genesis it's called perhaps you can
put a link in
i will does that also explain the
different
blood types all of it
is in that okay so if you look at
this statement that here from one blood
has made all nations then
i compared it there with uh the many
varieties of animals that we get and if
you take
the the canine family
they can all be derived back to the wall
yes even though
their genetics can differ vastly
the wolf can have 76 chromosomes
and some of the foxes have fewer
chromosomes
in the 30s 36 but if you
if you look at comparative
gene mapping you will see that
there are short chromosomes when we look
at the wolf with these
high number of chromosomes and long ones
when you have
the shorter the smaller number and
band mapping shows you that it's
actually
fusion of chromosomes and that the same
genetic material
is present in both but then you have all
the varieties of forms
shapes colors and if you take one
species like the dog
for example and then you can clearly see
that
the range that you can get out of that
wild type ranges from a chihuahua to a
great dane
and it's incredible
a little chihuahua doesn't know that
he's a chihuahua and he's quite happy to
attack a great day
thinking that he's the same size when
he's not
but this is the kind of variety that is
built into the gene system
so what is the difference between the
races
well the one has more pigmentation than
another one
but we have the same pigments there's no
such thing
as a white man or a white woman
we are pigmented this is certainly not a
white color
it's just less than in other people
so you have the entire spectrum so
where was adam adam was probably
somewhere in the middle he was
not white and he was not black
but he had the genetic potential for the
entire range and
all men were created from that
one wild gene
pair which was immaculate which was
perfect
which had no degeneracies no faults
all of humanity has
degenerated if you take
the bible and you look at the sizes of
the people how large
they were we must look puny
compared to them right and just the fact
that our teeth don't even fit anymore
tells us that we must have had a much
greater
structure originally so
exactly what we were like we don't
know and what we will be we don't know
but we will get
glorified bodies and new bodies
so if we are all made from one blood
then we are all related irrespective of
what
nationality race tribe creed
we belong to
now ephesians tells us in chapter 4 31
let all bitterness and wrath and anger
and clamor and evil speaking be put away
from you with all malice
that's quite a mouthful yeah
and be kind one to another tenderhearted
forgiving one another even as god for
christ's sake has
forgiven you the bottom line is this
once you understand where you come from
once you understand where you are
heading
once you have been called out of
babylonian thinking
with all its wrath and bitterness
and anger and clamor and evil speaking
you have to put that away yes you have
to become a new person
you have to view other persons in a new
view exactly you must you must look at
people in a different light you must
you must see the image of god yes
no matter how distorted that image has
become
if you take someone who's been subjected
to the drug
world and has been devastated
and you have rehabilitated a person like
that
you know i often think about
these these uh shows that they have
where they rescue animals for example
stray animals that are in the most
horrendous position
with those empty dull eyes
and you just take them out of this
position and you
you give them love and attention
how they blossom and how they change
that's how god works with us
he picks us up where we are and
he changes us into what we can become
and some of us have devastated lives
because of
drug use or what which crosses that the
color line it doesn't
drugs don't ask what color are you
and you have this destroyed humanity
and you have this possibility of
restoration
and if you take biblical examples mary
magdalene for example
where the bible says that seven times
god had to drive those demonic forces
out of her and this is the state of
humanity
but once god has redeemed you then we
must put away those things
and we must consider each other as
brothers and sisters
so a christian by definition
cannot be racist no now
have christians demonstrated racism
over the centuries definitely absolutely
so then what kind of christians were
they
not true to the word christian in other
words
they're giving lip service but once you
understand the
truth then these issues must become
prominent
now i'm quite proud to say that when
this church
was founded one of the great
issues that was in in that early time
a very prominent part of the discussion
was slavery and the racial issue
and this is one of the churches that
spoke out
most profoundly against that
injustice why because they had
recognized something in the scripture
which didn't
match the reality that they were seeing
with their own eyes
yes so man's inhumanity to man
should not be an excuse for those
who are living today who find
christ correct
genesis chapter 3 verse 4 and the
serpent said unto the woman
ye shall surely not die
you shall surely not die or you shall
not surely die which is the same thing
for god does know
that in the day you eat thereof then
your eyes shall be
opened and ye shall be as gods knowing
good
and evil those were the the three
issues of the serpentine doctrine that
we discussed
now if this is the doctrine of the
serpent
how does he integrate it into the
movements
that we see in the world today because
remember this is how
this is his his doctrine yes
this is this is his religion
so everything that he gets onto his side
is permeated with these lies and his
champion
the beast of revelation is the one
that like a mother hen incorporates all
of this under her wing
so we have to look for these elements in
in everything
in everything and if we find them
then we must know oops this is babylon
correct and what does god say must we do
get out of that come out of babylon
so everything is connected and you
cannot you cannot take something in
isolation
and discuss it and say oh this is wrong
and this is wrong and this is wrong we
must look at the system
and compare it with the biblical
scenario so for example pope francis
urges catholic media to help young tell
good from
evil does he use the bible to do this
no no so he's the one
that says he will determine what is good
and evil
and he will use the world media
to help young people to distinguish
between good and evil
i don't think the world's media
is going to be very helpful when it
comes to distinguishing between good and
evil
what do you think no so is the
television going to be your educator
well that's what he is asking for well
he uses the catholic press association
so
he he's also is referring to the news
right yes so
the news are supposed to help you now
decide
between good and evil
i don't think i don't think that this
is in harmony with what god wants us to
do
and unfortunately it is just the fact
that the media is being
used today as a propaganda tool
to whip up emotions
to the point where people at point blank
range will shoot each other i mean look
at that case the other day where that
security guard
shot that person to death because they
weren't wearing a mask
so who whipped them up into that
state of mind where there is a right way
and a wrong way according to the media
yeah
and we have to watch out for this kind
of thing don't let
the media become your educator
correct use the media to see what's
happening in the world
that's why we emphasize that you use the
biblical filters
to put all the media into their
categories
but don't get par become part of correct
but if the media is going to be a
propaganda machine
then you have to be very very very
careful
because the news that comes from them
from what filter did they use
and how much practice have they had over
the years
look how i mean i'm german right
just look how the whole mindset of a
whole nation
could be swung by propaganda into what
the whole world today
recognizes as a travesty of justice that
is
unparalleled in human history but
we are on the point of repeating it yeah
and improving upon it isn't it
amazing how um
the current situation in america
now trump is
openly against the fake news
yes i don't know if they've ever been a
president that's so outspoken
before against news agencies i've never
heard
in my life one speaking as prominently
as he does
but the point we are making here by
showing these things
is that the roman catholic church
as we showed in those lectures the
doctrine of the serpent
as the champion of those doctrines
has its finger in all of these pies
and here the pope is telling us that the
media
must be used to shape the minds
of the people particularly the young
people
what's also for me interesting is on
this issue from
the media now to tell you or help to
know
good and evil the lie is
that we can actually know between good
and evil
without the biblical that's right and
once you start going down that slippery
slope you can end anywhere
so with those points in mind let's have
a look from the
at the statement from testimonies for
the church volume two
we are forbidden to wrong our neighbor
in anything and as you said the word
neighbor
is totally colorblind right correct
we should not view the matter from the
world link standpoint that's exactly
what we've been saying
deal with our fellow men in every
instance just as we should wish them to
deal with
us is a rule which we should apply to
ourselves
practically god's laws
are to be obeyed to the letter in
all our intercourse and deal with our
fellow men
whether believers or unbelievers
this rule is to be applied love thy
neighbor as thyself
now not everybody has the same
circumstances
you get poor people you get rich people
you get violent people you get
calm people you get criminals
now criminality
is it something that is exclusive to a
particular race
no or do you get criminals in every race
in every tribe in every creed in every
nation
do you get murderers and rape rapists
in only one race
no it is something that happens
in every race yes because
sin is in the world exactly now war
and bloodshed and bombs falling from the
sky
are they colour dependent
or do they hit everyone everyone sorrow
pain is it
colored determined no
a mother that loses her child
the pain and the sorrow that they feel
is it color dependent no
shouldn't these things arouse human
compassion
so we have to look at these things very
carefully so
with that background let's look at this
issue
of black lives matter now
let's just say it because everywhere
black lives matter we're talking about
the movement we're not saying
the color or the life of any person
doesn't matter yes this is gonna this is
going into the movement and what should
be
looking at movements we're looking at at
uh
great events happening in the time that
we are living in
and we're placing them in categories
now it is true
that black lives matter of course but
it's also true
that white lives matter or any other
race's life
matters because in god there is no
difference
all have sinned and fall short of the
glory of god
and redemption is totally colorblind it
is open
to all who believe right correct
and once you become a believer you
become part of the heavenly family
that's the important thing don't we call
each other in the church brother and
sister
exactly and does that then cross the
color line as well
yes absolutely so what black lives
matter can teach catholics about
racial justice now this comes from the
jesuit review this is the journal
america so i'm always interested
in how these people think yes because
this is the mother church
that encompasses the doctrine of the
serpent
so let's just read the highlighted
portions otherwise we're going to take
forever
almost everyone i spoke with agreed that
the catholic church will not succeed in
its work towards racial
reconciliation unless the hierarchy
enters into dialogue with the black
lives matter
movement that's a fascinating thing
so a movement has arisen
and the only way to solve the racial
issue is for the church
to communicate with the movement
who says the movement is right who says
the church is right
what is the going to be the criteria and
then it tells us further
ms gaza one of the founders of the
movement would welcome
such dialogue the purpose of faith i
think
is to be connected to something bigger
than yourself
and to be able to carry out the agenda
of that
faith she says now
i believe it is quite possible
that this dialogue that they might have
might end up in a synthesis
and that church and this movement come
together
and form a synthetis and improve
racial relations as one of the anchors
on fox news
stated perhaps it would be useful
if there was a postural swap every now
and then
so that the churches that are
predominantly
black worshipers and those that are
predominantly filled with white
worshipers
come together and dialogue and also
have a pastoral swap let's say once a
month
so that we get to know each other better
because we have points
of common contact we all believe that
jesus is the one that saves us etc so
this would be a good movement
absolutely it could be a wonderful
movement
and it's not a bad idea but what if
and this is always my problem what if
there is a sting to the tail
what if with that synthesis and that
fusion
you're actually swallowing something
else
that is not biblical so if you have
a thesis and an antithesis which becomes
a synthesis
that doesn't mean that the synthesis is
right
correct correct
so again where do we apply the filter
what is
correct what is right what is good what
is evil
where is the difference where do i find
the answer
i find the answer in the bible
i don't see how the church can remain
outside
something as significant as black lives
matter
so here we have a little bell ringing
in our mind which says now wait a minute
a movement has been started and this
movement is going to
liaise with the church and out of that
will come a solution which might sound
good yes because you know this is
bringing healing
but is it true healing no
and what's interesting is this was in
february
of last year this is before the riots
before the riots
even started correct now
if you just think about riots
where you have riots and where you have
looting
is that love your neighbor as yourself
how would you like to be
on the other side of the fence
being the one that is looted so
it is contrary to the concept of love
your neighbor
any any form of violent action
um looting like you said it's also part
of the commandments
exactly and that falls under the
commandments of love your neighbor
for the six the the first four to god
and the last
yes towards uh it is true that there is
inequality
we cannot deny that the world is filled
with inequality
but it's not just across racial divides
there are social inequalities within
races
which are sometimes even more
prominent than those between races
so you know where's your criterium
here's a an article from breitbart the
complex
funding and ideology of black lives
matter so
we have to look at the movement and so
political and corporate support for
black lives matter has become
ubiquitous over the past week so there
is this movement
that the political world the social
world
the church world in other words the
whole
of the human community becomes involved
in this
and because it is such an explosive
issue it's
easy to say well i'm going to be part of
this movement
black lives matter major financial
supporters include
george soros open society foundation 33
million
bad robot productions film studio
involved in star trek star wars etc
pledged 10 million it was interesting
cisco electronics giants 5 millions to
the group
including blm and its own fighting
racism and discrimination fund so
there's this massive movement let's make
this thing right
but on what basis on what principle
u.s bishops caught funding radical
groups supporting riots calling for
death to the police this is very
interesting
what is going on this is from june a new
investigation
by the le panto intus institute has
revealed that the bishops in the united
states
through their catholic campaign for
human development
of funding organizations that support
riots
and whose goal includes not only
defunding police
but even killing them now
this must be pretty well orchestrated
because who would ever come up with an
idea that in the world that we are
living in that we have to get rid of the
police
uh in in certain areas
reform of policing is certainly
something that can be on the agenda but
nobody in his
in his uh right mind would come up with
the idea let's get rid of them
totally what what would that lead to we
would have anarchy right
i mean even god has put rulers of evil
over the evil yeah so
god has has invested
humanity with the power to control
these issues and that was one of the
promises made to cain
right in the beginning but that the
catholic church should be so
involved is always something that
puts up the antennae yes
so let us just look at a little bit of
the background
of the movement and see what the
ideologies are
that are involved i think of
a lot of things the first thing i think
is that we actually do have an
ideological frame
myself and alicia in particular are
trained organizers
we are trained marxists
we are
super versed
on sort of ideological theories
they are trained marxists now
karl marx said that
religion was a problem and lennon said
religion was a problem
and they had to keep god right out of
their meetings remember
yes it's fascinating to me how this
ideology
can now be mingled with the religion
and uh interesting yeah interesting
sentences
how for instance if we go back to the um
just the american article the jesuit
article that said they can learn from
each other
this is a faith thing so where is the
marxist and faith our
is this going to get together what is
the faith issue
so let's have a look at this interesting
article from the daily signal the ugly
racism of karl marx
now that's that's a oxymoron how can you
be trained
marxists and have marxist ideology
when karl marx was actually
quite blatantly racist few people who
call themselves
marxists have ever been bothered to read
das capital
if one did read it it would see that
people who call themselves
marxists have little in common with marx
for those who see marx as their hero
there are a few historical
tidbits that they might find interesting
nathaniel well himself a former
communist dug them up for his 1979 book
karl marx racist well marx
and engels made some comments that's
really
not fit for us to put on the screen so
but they were blatantly down
talking to the colored people correct
it's interesting that you can take an
opposite ideology
like fascism under adolf hitler for
example
and they were just as blessed blatantly
racist
saying that there was a superior race as
to opposed to other races
it's exactly the same thing it's totally
contrary to
the bible absolutely here's another
statement from
the spirit of prophecy gospel workers
counsels for the church
and it says there is a large vineyard
to be cultivated but while christians
are to work amongst unbelievers
they are not to appear like worldlings
they are not to spend their time talking
politics or acting politics for by
so doing they give the enemy opportunity
to come in
and cause variance and discord
i think that's a very important point
yes
god's children are to separate
themselves from politics
from any alliance with unbelievers
do not take part in political strife
separate from the world and refrain from
bringing
into the church or school ideas that
will lead to contention and disorder
dissension is the moral poison taken
into the system by human beings who are
selfish
now this is an incredible statement
we're supposed to
stand aloof from any such movements
and there's a good reason for that yes
once you start
taking aside you will automatically have
an
opposite side arrayed against you yes
and if you take that side
the same applies yeah and then you bring
it into the church and you've got
a split in the church and you have the
exact same chaos in the church
so once you embrace the truth once you
embrace
christianity your
fellow believers become your brothers
and sisters
and the differences must disappear
and if you have been programmed
through your social circumstances to
have
you know ideas which are contrary to
this
then you have to go onto your knees and
you have to ask god
to remove those ideas and thoughts
from your mind that's important and to
come back into harmony yes
and not get the bible to become in
harmony with your thoughts
no because there's a lot of people that
have done that i mean our own country
you cannot you cannot put the card
before the horse yes they
they use the bible to justify some
racial things exactly now as we said
before
throughout history there have been these
christians that have exactly done the
opposite
implemented slavery implemented all of
these things
and then it is labeled as the christian
that is actually doing this and the
christian becomes the enemy this is
exactly what we are seeing here yes
but true christianity
must be clearly distinguished
and god's people should be a
mirror for the world they should see
in god's people a different attitude
to the world they should see
a genuine regard and kindness
and respect amongst god's people
that does not exist out there in the
world
and people should say what is it that
makes them different unfortunately
we're not living in a perfect world and
we want to see this happening
until we get to the point
where our knees become as important to
us
as our prejudices were before exactly
sin also doesn't have a color attached
to it
no it's all color so can we take part in
any of
of such movements even if they have
principles with which we agree even if
there are principles of
unfairness we have to look at the old
the whole picture
and the answer is clearly no we cannot
we can agree with the sentiment but we
must
always put it in the context of the
bigger picture
let us look a little bit further into
the black lives matter and we'll see
what the ideology is besides marxism
because even marxism is a faith even if
it is a faith that
excludes god so it must include
something what does it
include let's have a look um and maybe
i'm sharing too much but we become very
intimate with the spirits that we call
on regularly
right like each of them seems to have a
different
presence and personality you know i
laugh a lot with wakisha
you know and i didn't meet her in her
body right i'm her through this work
um so i just want you to kind of speak
to that a little bit if you can
yeah i mean i'm um
you know i was always someone who almost
obsessed about our ancestors black
ancestors in particular
i wasn't raised with honoring ancestors
necessarily i was raised jehovah's
witness
a little bit opposite of that um
and as i got older and started to feel
like i was missing something ancestor
ancestral worship became really
important and as you know the fowler
museum
is so important because it has um
it has a bunch of west african
traditional
pieces inside that museum that was the
founders of the black lives matter
movement
and it's fascinating she stated that
she was raised jehovah's witness
now jehovah's witnesses also believe
that the dead sleep
but then she felt this power that was
moving
inside and it was ancestral
worship in other words making contact
with the ancestors
and that this was part of spirituality
that had to be
introduced and the host
also related stories of talking to
disembodied entities
now do you see the link there with
serpent
theology yes if the dead
know nothing if the dead no longer take
part in anything under the sun if the
dead no longer return to their homes
then these entities that are manifesting
themselves
are not ancestors but demonic forces
because they are speaking contrary to
the word of god
and therefore if you know what the
doctrine of the serpent
is and you know the situations if you
know
how they are linked one to another then
you can avoid these things
by applying your filter
so black lives matter is a spiritual
movement
and it's also a
marxist movement now let me just
get this straight marxism
which says there is no god
is that king of the south or king of the
north that's king of the south and
a spiritual movement that includes
ancestral worship is that king of the
south or king of the north the king of
the north so where are we now aren't we
at synthesis
so this movement is a synthesis
and i always find it fascinating to see
how these poles
actually come together with two
diametrically opposed philosophies
fusion yeah into one isn't that amazing
it is
so it's a spiritual movement says
co-founder patrice colors
abdullah and colors touched on the
practice of calling out the names of the
victims
that they advocate for in protests
and demonstrations it's kind of a way to
invoke the spirits
abdullah said uplifting the names of
victim
goes beyond creating hashtags colors
said it is literally among
almost resurrecting a spirit so they can
work
through us to get the work that we need
to get
done that's a very scary statement
would you like a spirit entity to work
through you
if you know that it's not an ancestor
because the bible tells you that that
ancestor is asleep
yes so it no it's a very scary thing
colors who grew up jehovah's witness
says she was always someone who all
almost obsessed about our black
ancestors
so this is a very interesting synthesis
that we are seeing here it is a
babylonian fusion and there is
babylonian wine
mixed in the mixed the dead
are not dead they surely did not die
this is serpent theology at its best can
i be part of it
yeah can i take any aspect of it and say
well i support that but not that
therefore i'm part of the movement
no then you like you said in the
previous one partly
influenced or partly part of babylon
exactly
now the same with the bible how much of
it must i
accept all of it is that
are they optional accessories no none no
it's a it's a package deal right
finished so the world
has this package which consists of all
these
these separate components that have
become a synthesis because
all of them contain something
that i will agree with and then i am
willing to pocket the some things that i
don't agree with
for the sake of unity yes is that a good
basis for unity that is
terrible it's like an economical
movement
you've hit the nail on the head the
economical movement is exactly the same
let us not concentrate on our
differences
let us concentrate on that which unites
us
and then we'll throw jesus into the
waste paper basket
because the less we mention him the
better we get along yes
african ancestor believes now this
article here
comes from the southern cross which is
the official
southern africa catholic weekly magazine
and we're not going to go through the
whole article i think it's about 11
pages long
but the summary is what we're interested
in right
how are they going to see this most
if not all black catholics within the
archdiocese of cape town south africa
pray to their ancestors they know this
ancestor worship
is the african mode of worship
since the african ancestor system of
belief has survived
two centuries of christian mission
in other words couldn't wipe it out
we look at the theology of the communion
of the saints
for possible coherence with this very
important
system of belief so is there a link
between catholicism and ancestor worship
yes
absolutely i mean roman catholics have
sent communion in fact roman catholics
teach that you can communicate
with the godhead through the saints you
solicit the aid of the saints
what's the difference between that an
ancestor worship
no nothing uh the communion of the
saints in roman catholic thinking goes
further
at every mass that he said
those on the other side that are dead
are participating
so you have a communion of the living
and the dead
in every mass that is spiritism
at its highest level and
it is forbidden by god yes because
necromancy the worship of the dead or
the calling of the dead
is forbidden by god yes now can you see
how
roman catholicism
is the one that can incorporate all the
religious systems
under its wings because it has
something forever yes it caters inside
of its theology for
every religion that there is the spirit
of prophecy says that she's
perfectly situated
to accommodate those who want to be
saved by their works
and those who want to be saved in their
sins
and they the bishops or are not um shy
to admit
that you can use buddhist mantras or
ways of prayer
to do in catholicism and that's just one
of them
that is the biggest oxymoron i've ever
heard of in my life
because buddhism by its very nature
does not believe in a person or god
and when you take it to its ultimate end
this is very strange because the
ultimate
position that you can reach is nirvana
which is the state of nothingness
how it has become possible
that a theology can be created where the
state of
nothingness which is the state of of
the dead eventually
as described in the bible becomes the
ultimate
achievement is amazing
christianity says i've come to give you
life and to give it to you to the full
whereas this philosophy says that you
empty yourself can you
bring this philosophy of totally empty
yourself
becoming nothing and denying a personal
god
can you fuse this with the religion of a
person or god no it's impossible they're
diametrically opposed so again you have
a thesis and an antithesis and you have
a synthesis
yes so let's just read this again
since the african ancestor system of
belief has survived two centuries of
christian mission
we look at the theology of the communion
of the saints for possible coherence
with this very
important system of belief so they admit
there's no difference
this theology satisfies us that those
who have gone before us
are not asleep what does the bible say
doctrine of the serpent 100 in your face
there
absolutely and the bible says they do
sleep absolutely the bible says they are
asleep
jesus says lazarus sleepeth
they are asleep they have no more
to do under the sun this is incredible
so rome categorically says they're not
asleep the bible says they are asleep
but are a constant presence to us the
bible says they have
nothing to do with anything under the
sun
in fact job tells us that uh
they're standing at the grave and he
doesn't even know it
whereas they preach he's standing right
with us and looking at us and smiling at
us right
having experienced immediate judgment
after death
which is not biblical because he has set
a day
in which he will judge the world this is
totally contrary to the gospel and to
the bible
and immediate reward or punishment
which is not true because that comes
after the resurrection
right and are in a real time
communication with us contrary to the
bible yes
jesus says i come with my reward
yes and here they say your reward is
immediate
exactly what's the point of him saying i
will come again
so that you can be where i am also which
implies that you are not with him
where he is also what's the point the
whole gospel is negated
this is the way the sadducees used to
think
i contend that it is not only the
canonized
saints who are in contact with us but
all those in heaven and purgatory as
well
oh now they can even get out of
purgatory to come and communicate with
you
because it would be hard for them to get
rid of purgatory right
and remember why was there a purgatory
in the first place
so that you can pay for forgiveness
exactly because
rome teaches that christ never died for
you
you still have to pay for your own sins
he didn't
bear your the price for your sins
he didn't pay that price you are
responsible
for your own salvation that's salvation
by works yes
so this is also contrary to the bible
as there is no doubt from the documents
of the church
that these are in communion with us
that also this is beautiful this is
i couldn't have done it better thank you
southern cross
it acknowledges everything that you've
said before
the doctrine of the serpent so what in
convinces of this
the documents of the church
not the bible not the bible isn't this
fascinating yes
they are so amazing
let's read the highlighted poet in the
same way
that african ancestors need
acknowledgement
for by their progeny but for different
reasons
our departed need prayers to facilitate
the process of purification
purgatory so in other words rome
teaches that your purification
continues on the other side with
the penalty purgatory the suffering to
pay
the price for the sins totally negating
the gospel of salvation
those who have gone before us no doubt
have a very special
interest in our well-being and being
present
to us will no doubt pray for us
there is no problem then in seeing the
departed as a benign
presence with our best interests at
hearts
there are many experiences narrated
subjective
admittedly of some type of assistance
and communication
received from our departed family
members
ancestors are seen as mediators between
god
and humankind the bible tells
us that there are how many mediators
only one are you sure yes
the man christ but you are at variance
with the roman catholic church now
we're at variances with quite a few
people at this stage
now this is incredible so here again
what the bible teaches and what the
roman catholic
church teaches are two different things
yes
and it is very clear this is their
official mouthpiece
this is not as some would like to say an
obscure source
all the black catholics whom i have
questions pray to their ancestors
there is no mysterious invoking of
spirits
all also pray to jesus
now this is totally it's a fusion again
a confusion
what you have here is a synthesis of a
truth
with a lie and it is fascinating
that the lie always rides on the back of
truth to make it
acceptable but it doesn't make it any
less a lie
so when you accept jesus christ
do you then rid yourself of the
babylonian
baggage that you have picked up
throughout your life and how do you
know what to get rid of bible study
yes the word of god
must purify the soul
and once the word tells you something
and the holy spirit convicts you that
that is truth
then everything else must be set aside
and become part of the babylonian
confusion
which you set aside and do not
take as baggage with you yes
so they have made it very clear to us
that this whole movement together with
the church
is completely compatible with their
theology
but also completely incompatible
with the bible yes with true
christianity yes
so let us have a look at some of these
issues how the papacy actually embraces
all of these ideologies not only with
african nations but also that of other
nations
[Music]
that was the ritual with pachamama
now she is mother earth yes i think it's
for the fertility mother earth god
idol goddess and he was quite happy to
embrace it and make it part of
his system so
lifesight tells us amazonian woman
who led vatican tree planting ceremony
reveals its pagan
and then there's her name olivieriana
who also guided participants in bowing
down around pachamama
statues during the october 4th ceremony
said regarding the event the synod is to
plant
this tree water and cultivate
so that the amazonian people are heard
and respected in their customs and
traditions experienced
the mystery of the divinity present
in the amazonian soil
that is pantheism yes that
is blatant pantheism and it's totally in
harmony
with the theology of pope francis
whose encyclicals are permeated with
pantheism
in section 70 pope francis states that
the church needs to listen
to the ancestral wisdom here again
we have the official position of the
roman catholic church
that ancestral worship is part and part
of the system
of the amazon region he states that the
church needs to listen
once more to the voice of the amazon
elders so in other words the
accumulated wisdom pantheistic wisdom
over the eons and here we're going to
see
how nature worship and earth worship
are being fused this is a synthesis
right
yeah we are going to fuse the various
systems of belief into a synthesis
we're going to add a mix of earth
worship
into the system gaia worshiped
and we're going to grant mother earth
the rest
that she requires yes and then you have
the full
babylonian confusion all in one
nice package they asked the question
here did pope francis defend
pachamama idolatry at the vatican
in new amazon synod exhortation
well profound states that the people
should not be quick to describe
as superstition or paganism certain
religious practices
that arise spontaneously from the life
of the peoples
now whenever rome evangelized an area
like when the jesuits went to south
america
they not only exploited those poor
people
they created the reductions upon which
communism is basically based
and in those reductions they used these
people basically as
slave labor and often made them
dependent
on drugs and the drug industry arose
out of this movement
and they would not negate their
religious practices
with catholicism but incorporate them
and fuse them yes into a synthesis
and this is the power of catholicism
this is how you
gather a nation into your fold you just
change the names of the deities
but they're still the same deities and
you can worship the old ones in parallel
parallel to the new so
pope francis hosted a pagan ceremony
with pachamama statues in the vatican
gardens and even blessed one of the
statues
that we saw in the video is that
contrary to the second commandment
yes at the ceremony people were bowing
down
to the ground worshiping the statue is
that contrary to the second commandment
yes what did rome do with the second
commandment
they took it out
[Music]
additionally they probe prayed in front
of the pachamama statue at the saint
peter's cathedral on october
7 and then accompanied them in
procession
into the centered hall is that contrary
to the command
so now how do we integrate all of this
into one package
the bible warns us that there will be
this integrated package
and that people will have to make a
choice between
the system which the bible calls babylon
and the truth so basically we've seen
the roots of the black lives matter
movement
and we've come to the conclusion that
there is a synthesis in there
which makes it a very dangerous movement
if there were a similar movement
let's say white lives matter and it
integrated
the same sort of principles then exactly
the same would apply
exactly so the slogan that a christian
should adopt is
all lives matter yes because jesus came
to die
for all of mankind
all of mankind you know
i've spoken we live in africa spoken to
many
many people of every race
and tribe and people have often said to
me in
in my own country that
christianity is a white man's religion
christianity didn't originate in europe
no it's not a white man's religion
and christianity did not originate in
africa
it uh originated in the middle east
right
yes so christianity originated in the
east and spread across the entire world
and yes it is based upon jesus christ
who is the messiah who did become a
human being
and was part of a specific race the jews
but he was god manifest in the flesh in
the beginning was the word and the word
was with god
and the word was god
and in his glorified form
he shines like the sun and the european
has the choice to accept this truth and
the african has a choice to accept this
truth
and the asian has a choice to accept
this truth and so has every single
nation
because this gospel will be preached
unto all the world
all nations so now having
having basically seen what the roots of
the black lives matter movement was
and how it is integrated with the the
lie of the serpent
and how is it integrated with the roman
catholic system
because all power is going to be given
unto the beast therefore the beast must
be prominent in all of this
let's have a look at the mark of the
beast how this will be incorporated
because we've seen mother earth worship
now yes
and mother earth must be granted the day
of rest
and uh so we're going to
that amazon senate that were
at the vatican and doing this rituals
and everything that was
in september october of 2019
during that celebration um
i think i don't know how long it is of
saint francis for the earth and
everything and we've touched on that
in that document of jubilee for the
earth
yes because that jubilee of the earth
were
already preparing for this year's
getting together and celebrating that
and now
there's a new or an add-on also to this
that's freedom sunday it's also
interesting that
uh some people weren't too happy with
those rituals and actually stole those
statues and
yes and threw them into the river didn't
they yes yes some of the
more conservative catholics yes so let's
have a look at this
article here dedicate one sunday at your
church
to end slavery now slavery
is very much associated with black lives
matter
so now sunday is being brought into the
mix
yes so we have a movement which is
supposed to train humanity
in the right direction in terms of
racial prejudice
so we can all agree on that but because
of the mix
that is in there we have to separate
ourselves from movements like that and
not
seen marching with a movement
that is in any way integrated with this
babylonian
concept so now sunday is brought into
the mix
freedom sunday is an invitation
for your congregation to learn about
slavery
it's never freedom monday or tuesday or
anything like it has to be sunday right
this is even if it sometimes starts off
on a friday or something eventually it
comes back
and it it ends up to being a sunday it
must be a sunday
so and your church can help send rescue
to children women
and men living in slavery pledge a date
for your freedom
sunday or join the global freedom sunday
movement
on sunday the 20th of september
when you host freedom sunday you will
and then it tells you what you
will all be involved in you see this
adds on or links on to the um
jubilee for the earth type of movement
because this is also they encourage
churches to get on board with us yes
it's
a global movement it sounds like a good
movement
and people that have swallowed a little
porsche of the babylonian story here and
a little bit there
eventually will move along whether they
are religious or not
yes because it it accommodates all of
them
that's what the synthesis is all about
here is uh join our freedom sunday
movement
on freedom sunday churches all around
the world
come together as a united hopeful
justice driven
community seeking to end modern slavery
the concept is fine but what are the
hooks attached to it exactly
we start with prayer lament
learning dialogue worship to inform and
catalyze our response
to the global tragedy now if this takes
place
all over the world will ancestral
worship be part of it in some places
yes obviously yes freedom sunday is more
than a day
it's more than a worship service freedom
sunday is a movement
of hope so sunday is linked
to hope yes will government become
involved
well yes according to the bible it will
so church and state will come together
on this issue
so we must see the state acting a role
and eventually the state is the one that
enforces
legislation so let's have a look at a
little
video clip and see how this pans out
in the concept of prophecy
he also happens to be the most resilient
the most courageous the most
faith-friendly
president in the history of america
president
donald trump president trump we love you
vice president pence working alongside
our great
president and together they have been
able to enact
the most pro-life pro-religious liberty
pro-israel pro-conservative judiciary
in the history of america
it is good to be back in church
it is the faith of the american people
that has sustained us through every dark
hour of this
nation's history and it is the faith
of the american people that will sustain
us through these days
other ancient words that have been over
the fireplace
in our home in indiana in the governor's
residence
in the vice president's residence today
they read for i know the plans i have
for you
plans to prosper you and not to harm you
plans to give you a hope
and a future and i believe with all my
heart
on this celebrate freedom sunday and
every day
that if we will but hold fast to him
we'll see our way through these
challenging times we will restore
our nation's health we will renew our
freedom
and we will inspire people across this
land with our witness of the love
and compassion and strength that comes
in a personal relationship with jesus
christ
thank you for letting me
god bless you
my young brother
these are rousing words on the freedom
sunday right
now if you are seen to be
contrary and not wishing to take part in
any of this
how will you be viewed as an enemy
as an enemy of hope yes as an
enemy of everything that the system
stands for
the big problem that i also see is
everywhere
disaster is happening in various
and everywhere this calls for unified
prayer
and get togethers and all of this but
it's
this is where it's getting dangerous
it's getting dangerous and if you
if you uh avoid the system in its
entirety
then you will be seen as being against
all the little elements that are inside
of it yes
so even if you are the most anti-racist
person in the world you will be labeled
the racist yes because you don't want to
get
part because of the movement
and if you are on the side of the
scripture in terms of the day
of worship you will be
designated an enemy of hope
and unity i can easily see
how god's people will end up being the
pariahs
being the ones that have to be
exterminated off the face of the earth
yes yes the catholic news agency
catholic bishop urges uk to preserve
sunday as a day of rest and
these are all very new right yeah this
comes from
june 2020 if degrading sunday as a day
of rest or family of community
of worship marginally enhanced or
faltering economy
it would not be justified because of its
deeper
impact upon human well-being
this is a moment for us to raise our
voices so our christian
sunday is not discarded by a political
slight of hand and they bring it in with
a monthly sunday
and eventually it will become a weekly
sunday because the earth needs it
french archbishop calls for monthly
lockdown
on sunday now this is getting more
interesting
we now see a link between a pandemic
and sunday yes so you need
a monthly lockdown sunday could that be
expanded to a
weekly lockdown sunday
definitely they can say it's for your
health it's for your health
they can say it's for climate change
they can say it's for
they can use it for everything for
anything so you can reach the secular
mind and you can reach the religious
mind right
you need a time for contemplation you
need this time to
to consider the evils of humanity and to
set the record straight
we need to put shoulder to shoulder
and mixed into this bowl which is called
babylonian confusion
you swallowing all of the other issues
for the sake of unity yes amazing
now just a thought
the mark of the beast that will be
implemented and rome plainly says the
mark of our ecclesiastical power is that
we changed
the saturday to the sunday
so it is a mark of their authority in
religious matters and the whole world
follows the dictates of the roman
catholic church right they even mock
protestants
with regard to that now here they're
linking
sunday to a pandemic
to a disease if you look at the bible
and you look at the warning against the
mark of the beast
part of that warning is called
the right arm of the gospel which is the
health message
in other words the true mark of god
is associated with a health issue
so the false mark is also associated
here with the health message isn't that
incredible that's how the devil works
is that he's a copycat the whole time to
the nth degree
so now here is linking a pandemic a
disease
to the mark of the beast saying that it
is paramount that we all work together
on this issue
and that we receive the mark of the
peace
and the counter message is do not accept
the mark of the peace
and there's a health message associated
with that too
a message that doesn't say that you have
to wear a mask which is a symbol of
slavery by the way
it's a message that says that god will
use
the natural remedies in the world to
rid you of disease god is a healer
here is an enforced healing
and there is a voluntary healing
so you have a truth linked to a health
message
and you have a falsehood linked to a
health message i find this very
interesting
and in the mix you had the sunday
correct
is that mind-blowing yes publicly
absolutely
so the international catholic news
weekly
french bishops conference head
archbishop
eric molin beaufort has said
the recent pandemic shutdown had shown
both the planet and
its people needed a real day of sunday
rest
and suggested france designate one
sunday a month
as a locked down day
that's how you start like a cat we had a
cat
that used to sleep on the dog
he used to sleep on top of the dog and
the dog
tolerated it but then the dog got old
and it started getting eggs and pans and
it wasn't too keen
that the cat should lie on it anymore
and it was so funny to watch because the
cat would come
and try and climb on in the dog
and the cat would sit there and then the
cat would
put one paw on and when that paw was on
eventually the other paw and it was a
process and if there was a little growl
it would freeze
but eventually it ended up on the dollar
on the dollar every single time yes
this is how they're doing exactly
many have heard the birds again i hear
you have nature coming in it is amazing
and they've been able to observe the
arrival of spring
like never before in their lifetime
incredible
beautiful admitting it was probably a
waking dream
he suggested a monthly real sunday rest
for people but also for
cities for the earth
sunday has been
separated from a purely
christian context to a pagan conflict
it's amazing
if you read the the sabbath
everything in the bible regarding the
sabbath this is what the sabbath was
supposed to be like
yes you were supposed to enjoy nature
nature was supposed to enjoy the god of
nature
exactly but you were supposed to have a
communi a personal communication now
you're talking to dead people
and dead signs that are asleep that know
nothing
now here is a country that is not a
christian country
it's a hindu country and they are in
jerusalem introducing this
more so than many other nations i find
this very interesting so
you know it doesn't it doesn't stay with
the christian culture
it is a universal movement
strict action against sunday lockdown
violators so here the law
comes into effect and very soon
[Music]
you will have to maybe even have proof
of your vaccination
and there will be just as
strict measures to make sure
that you comply with the law
so the city police have made elaborate
security arrangements for
sunday lockdown this is incredible
the commissioner tweeted the lockdown
begins at 8 p.m
on saturday and concludes at 5 00 a.m
on monday they make sure that the whole
of the sunday is
in there right respected citizens
just stay at home and don't ask for
exceptions
as this is being done in everybody's
interest
heavens won't fall if you postpone by a
day please
exercise self-discipline and cooperate
pretty adamant
i just want to say i think if anybody
had a doubt
and how quickly they can decide
to put a law on a sunday just have a
look around the world what's happened
with this covet 19
absolutely and then there are still
people that say it's not happening
because it doesn't matter if the people
have protests right or whatever if the
government if it says
it's in it's in you don't have even a
que
where about it why is it
that even within our own ranks people
say this is not it
because they expect it to come on
religious
terms yes now what if it doesn't what if
it comes in via the back door
there's so many avenues that the devil
will cover
you can't just come you won't make it it
doesn't matter how it comes yes the fact
of the matter is there
it's coming so i wish that our people
could wake up and see where we are
in the stream of time and by the way we
haven't
mentioned one conspiracy in this entire
little talk this is all straight
from the news this is from july
2020. so this
is not something that we are inventing
this is a reality
united news of india curfew on sundays
to control
covets and i have a curfew yeah and that
was a
a certain district in india i think this
is a different district so this is a
different district
so it's amazing how this virus can be
controlled with a day
there's no curfew monday or tuesday or
wednesday or curfew saturday for that
matter
it's a curfew sunday that'll help
yes it's interesting i failed to see the
logic but
it's interesting you can link anything
once you have started the the synthesis
linkage you can you can add anything
to that list anything you remember in
the previous one where we had the
great reset yes they linked everything
back to climate change and then
eventually comes back to sunday
it doesn't matter you it doesn't matter
what you do you're coming back to this
issue
but there's no talk of it lockdown
restrictions to be
tightened in yanam region on sunday so
this is something that is happening
even in countries that are not
supposedly christian and
we've seen mike pence speaking on
those days so this is something that is
happening
universally and just to remind our
readers again we've had this on the
on the screen uh many times now
but this is a very interesting yeah this
is the voice for the faithful catholic
that they want to bring back those blue
laws
and that the netflix binge and the
lockdown is over and now is the time to
consider our heritage and go
back to sunday this movement is powerful
this movement is on a roll
and my personal conviction is
that the momentum that the enemy has
achieved
in setting this ball rolling it's not
going to be stopped
what is the point of putting a stop to
it
and saying back to square one you would
have to do this
all over again and that is why i am
pretty sure
that we are in the final events many of
our people believe
no we're not this is just a hiccup along
the road
things will go back to normal
it'll never go back to normal this
is going to go through to finality
yes how long we don't know
revelation 12 17 and the dragon was
wrath with a woman and went to make war
with the remnant of her seed which
keep the commandments of god and have
the testimony of jesus
obviously this is the very last step
everything must be in place before you
can launch this
wall yes is he getting his package
together
is he linking all faiths ancestral and
otherwise
into one great movement and then linking
it to the church
and then linking it to sunday and then
finding
someone who is common to go along with
it yeah
and once everybody be looking at that
one and
saying what's the matter with you
are you anti-humanity are you
anti-everything are you anti-hope are
you
everything this is the final movement
and we're heading towards it prophecy is
fulfilling
before our very eyes may god grant us
wisdom
we need it we need it and our people
need to wake us
and i pray that not only our people but
that the whole of humanity
can make this comparison the word of god
as opposed to this great babylonian
confusion may we make the right decision
will you pray for us
our heavenly father we need you so badly
in this time of the earth's history
please help us to treat our neighbor as
we would
treat ourselves and not see any color
and that we can see with clarity
what is happening in and around the
world and around
where we are can you bless us and also
bring us together
and help us in these times in jesus name
amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe
click here when the bell appears
click again to get notifications to
watch the next video
click here thank you